el coronavirus ha matado a más de 20
médicos en la paz durante enero los
galenos bolivianos ahora serán los
primeros en ser vacunados pero en lugar
de sentirse afortunados por la llegada
de un primer lote para la inmunización
de 10.000 médicos para jesse piscis mo
porque recibirán la vacuna sputnik 5
porque no dejan que venga otra
importadora y que traiga tan neox
vacunas porque el gobierno solamente
quiere importar y todavía una vacuna que
entre comillas no saben su eficacia que
es la va con las rosas bolivia compro
5.2 millones de dosis de la sputnik 5
otras 5 millones más de las producidas
por astrazéneca y espera una donación de
5 millones adicionales de la cooperación
internacional sin embargo las vacunas
rusas han llegado primero y son las que
levantan polémica en las calles como
somos un país emergente diseminan país
del sur que ahora se utiliza este
término creen que pueden hacer
experimentos con nosotros
y creo que vamos a hacer los conejillos
de indias no es posible que un gobierno
no proteja a sus ciudadanos
las vacunas rusas han sido criticadas
internacionalmente porque son inoculadas
en la población sin cumplir con todas
las etapas de su desarrollo y por una
falta de transparencia sobre su eficacia
el gobierno boliviano además ha sido
criticado por la demora en una
vacunación a gran escala algo de lo que
culpa a la presidenta transitoria
jeanine áñez si el gobierno de facto se
hubiera ocupado de hacer lo que
correspondía en lugar de pretender
obtener ilegales beneficios económicos
para sus allegados ya estaríamos en este
momento aplicando las vacunas a nuestra
población como ocurre en otros países en
tanto a los bolivianos sólo les queda
esperar porque no tienen otra
alternativa para afrontar la pandemia